On November 8th, the US will hold
475 separate federal elections.
If you vote in the US, you can vote
in at least one of them.
The results will determine
who controls these:
the two houses of Congress.
After the 2020 election, Democrats
controlled the House of Representatives
and the Senate, as well as
the Presidency.
The three bodies
that have to align
if you want to make
new laws.
And they did.
But even when government is split
between the parties.
Each one of these bodies
still holds
tremendous power
on its own.
So the importance of what
this picture looks like
can't be overstated.
And each one of these
three outcomes
contains a very different story
about the next 2 years in the US.
Scenario 1: Democrats
keep both houses.
This is not considered
the most likely outcome.
The Democrats have gotten a ton passed
in the last two years.
My name's Li Zhou.
I am a politics reporter
at Vox.
I've been covering the hill for
over 6 years now.
So if Democrats get to stick with
this arrangement...  then what?
One of the big things that
they've said they'll do
is codify Roe V. Wade
into federal law,
and that would mean
a national protection for
access to abortion.
Paid family leave, subsidies
for child care,
universal pre-K, the PRO act which
protects people's ability
to organize and unionize.
But there's a catch
to all this.
And it's connected to the reason Democrats
haven't done any of it yet.
These laws are subject to a rule
the Senate has
(It's called the filibuster)
that requires not 51 out of 100
votes to pass a law...
but 60 out of 100.
And Democrats want to
change that rule.
Just... not all Democrats.
They have this 50/50
very narrow majority
but they only have 48 who are actually
down to change the rules.
And so they need at least 52,
is kind of the magic number
that Democrats have been
hoping for, in order to both
change the rules, and then
pass a lot of the bills
that we've talked about.
Scenario 2: Republicans win
the House of Representatives.
When the House is controlled
by a different party
than the presidency
or the Senate.
That gives them a lot of leverage.
My name's Dylan Matthews.
I'm a reporter at Vox.
They also have a lot of control
over investigations.
They can run committees.
They can subpoena people.
They can make people testify.
They can dredge up documents.
We can see that by going back
to the last time the government
looked like this.
One thing that the GOP majority
in 2011 and onward did
was investigate
the Obama administration extensively.
The "fast and furious"
gun smuggling scandal,
on the Benghazi scandal after
those attacks happened in 2012.
"-Easily obtained...."
"Well, but Senator, again—"
"Within hours, if not days."
After Democrats won in 2018...
They also launched
a bunch of investigations
into the Trump administration,  one of which
culminated in the first impeachment.
Investigations can matter a lot.
More often than not,
they're kind of a sideshow.
My sense ahead of time
is that that lever of power
will be less important
than the ability to block
must-pass legislation
on spending and
the debt ceiling.
The debt ceiling fight in 2011
was one of the first stories I covered
at The Washington Post.
The debt ceiling is this limit
on how much the federal government
can borrow.
Almost the entirety of the
international financial system
is built on the idea that
US Treasury bonds are a safe asset.
Once you hit the debt ceiling,
they are no longer a low risk asset.
That would lead to investments,
and borrowing, and homes
and everything
being way more expensive
throughout the world
which would be a pretty major
financial crisis.
You need the House and Senate
and the President
to agree for the debt
ceiling to be raised.
The most dramatic example of that
happened in the summer of 2011.
The debt ceiling was coming
due in early August.
That gave House Speaker John Boehner
and members of his caucus
incredible leverage. Unless
the Obama administration
was willing to let the debt ceiling
be breached,
they kind of had to come to a deal.
Ultimately, $2.1 trillion in cuts
to the National Parks, Head Start programs,
the FBI
National Institutes of Health,
the National Science Foundation.
One area of the budget
is pandemic prevention.
The choice that was made
to invest a lot less
in preventing pandemics
as a part of this deal..
It certainly couldn't have helped.
I mostly expect this Congress
to be more hard-line,
in terms of their demands and
unwillingness to compromise.
Scenario 3: Republicans win
the House and the Senate.
The Senate has to confirm
any federal judge.
I'm Ian Millhiser,
I'm a lawyer
and I cover the Supreme Court
for Vox.
The president nominates
anyone who's going to be appointed
to the federal bench
but they don't get the job
unless a majority of
the Senate votes
to confirm that individual.
There's a little more than 800
active judges in the federal system.
There are district judges
who try cases,
Court of Appeals or
circuit judges.
And then there's
the Supreme Court.
The last time we had a Democratic president
and a Republican Senate
was in 2015 and 2016.
Under Barack Obama,
the Republican Senate
basically hit stop on
Supreme Court confirmations
and on nearly all
Court of Appeals confirmations.
And then, of course,
what happened was
Republicans held all those seats open
until Donald Trump
got into office
and then filled them
with Republicans.
Trump's judges have
overruled Roe v. Wade,
which is the reason why abortion
is now illegal in many US states.
A sweeping reinterpretation
of the Second Amendment,
our firearms amendment.
And now judges are striking down
gun laws left and right.
A wholesale attack on voting rights,
particularly on the Voting Rights Act,
which is the law that prevents
race discrimination.
At the lower court level,
we just had three Trump judges
declare the entire
Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau unconstitutional.
If Republicans take the Senate
then they can block the confirmation
of any judge.
If you hold those seats open,
they're still vacant when a Republican
comes to office,
and then the Republican
can fill them.
The Republican Party
which is an institution
that wants power...
has figured out that if
it controls the judiciary,
it can gain, potentially,
a permanent veto power
over any law that's enacted
over any regulatory policy
that's enacted
regardless of who controls
the White House
and regardless of who
controls the Congress.
They're going after
voting rights hard.
And if you don't have
the right to vote
then you don't have any rights.
Eventually, the voters who've
been disenfranchized
don't have any recourse
because they have no way to change
who controls the government.
And the government is controlled by people
who don't share their interests.
So that's the worst case scenario.
Right now, we're still
at the point where
you know, elections are the
best method that can be used
in order to reverse
America's democratic decline.
Out of the 475 individual
House and Senate elections
that will decide control of Congress...
most of them are not close races.
The election will really be decided
by these races...
only about 1 out of 7
House elections
and just a handful of Senate races.
And so if you live in
one of those places...
it means you have a lot of power over
which one of these we choose.